all right so i think we are good to
begin with today's session
i would like to welcome you all for the
first session of getting started with
bioinformatics in art
so let's quickly discuss that why this
program and what are we going to discuss
today
so as biology is saturated with complex
data sets that have to be sorted
explored and looked into anyone handling
data generation analysis or decision
making based on data has to gain some
level of data science skills and the
increasing necessity to process big data
and develop algorithms in all fields of
science means that programming is
becoming an essential skill for
scientists with python the language and
also the art of choice for the majority
of bioinformaticians
in most biological and biomedical
settings you will be expected to run or
implement programs written in art and
python scripting and others
so getting started can be hard
programming is like learning a new
language altogether and that is why we
offer easy to follow structured and
simple coding tutorials designed around
bioinformatics challenges
so without any delay let's get started
with today's session
but before uh we explain
what we're going to cover and also get
started with the session i would quickly
like to introduce us
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries and over 300
workshops and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
define the local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations
developing a training program for
research oriented students faculty and
democratizing bioinformatics making this
discipline accessible to thousands of
students and faculty around the world
omixologic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine bionic and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
i would like to take the honor to also
introduce the founders and team members
of the company dr alfred tauber comes
from a medical background with an
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of information and one of
his major projects is the establishment
of the double bioinformatics resource
center which has been at the core of
what we do
dr dr leonard brodsky is the director of
the double bioinformatics research
center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics and our
platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people who are mentioned
here on the right julia panoff is an
expert bioinformatician avitovsky leads
the development of the t bioinfo
platform dr mohit is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and dr raghavendran is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large scale analysis of
multi-omics data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
protein dna structural bioinformatics
and my name is sunali khari and i am the
omixlogic community manager and i am
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of a
community managed by buying biotech
so now let's quickly get up for today's
session
so the very first important thing that
you all need to do
is to make sure that you have an account
on the omixlogic learn portal because
today we are going to take you through
the resources on the portal we'll be
practicing the sessions as well uh in
the console on the portal itself so it's
very important for all of you to make
sure that you have an account i'll
quickly give a demo to those who have
joined the
session
and have not created an account yet
so this is the
link to the portal
it's in the chat box
everybody yes
and i'll just give a quick demo how you
can sign up if you are not done yet and
those who have signed up please let me
know in the chat box so that i know we
are good to begin
or all right so you need to click on the
login button
and
then you can either sign up by creating
an account for yourself
putting in the details required or
simply use any one of your social media
accounts to have an account on the
portal it's absolutely free of cost um
now
i will be doing it with one of my google
accounts
you can create an account right away so
that if you face any technical issue or
i am here to help you out with it
and also i'm awaiting responses in the
chat box from the people who have
already signed up
let's wait for a minute or so so that we
all
uh have an account and we can follow the
resources along the mentor
perfect christine thank you for the
confirmation
what about others
all right so i'm hoping that you you
have signed up or if not then you have
the link in the chat box please do so
the next thing is after you have created
your account please make sure that you
have updated your profile you need to
make sure that you have a profile
picture connect your social media links
and also add a brief file about yourself
so today the first session i have
invited uh
those who had a clean interest to be a
part of the program but have not yet
enrolled right so those who have
enrolled make sure that you have a
starter subscription active that is
going to give you the access to all the
starred lessons on the portal and also
make sure that you have a badge of
getting started with our on your profile
if you do not have a badge or if you do
not have a starter subscription button
here please let me know and i'll
activate the same for you
the next thing is that having a complete
profile is very important because we are
going to monitor your progress
uh
by your profile
so whichever step you are whichever
lesson you complete will get a
notification about your achievement by
your profile itself
and once you have completed a particular
course on the portal related to the
program you will be certified for the
very same program here in the profile
tabs itself go to the certificate
section and once you have the particular
course completed you will get a
certificate here you can also look at
your certificates for various coursework
that you complete along each and every
session of the program and also on
completion of the program you're going
to get your program certificate here
under uh
the programs section
so that was it about certification and
profiling now the next important thing
before we get started is to actually
see how to navigate on the portal
so when you click on on the courses tab
the very first thing as a part of the
program you're going to have the access
to all of the courses on the portal on
multi omics data analysis and data
science for r and python for
bioinformatics
each and every course you have an access
to and also the example projects
now how do you navigate either you
simply write r so because we have the r
session at present uh we'll be having
the python session after an r for the
ones who registered for python
so uh you need to go through the r
lessons specifically our coding course
one is here and our coding course two is
here
now the very first course work uh our
course course one is an introductory
sort of course work which will help you
just get started with r
and in the second coursework you will be
able to uh work with some
statistical analysis and also learn
about various visualizations and
definitely practice it alongside and
have one for your own data set
all right
this is what i wanted to uh show about
our lessons also it's very simple to
look at all of the courses that are
there on the portal just click click on
the course tag that is there on the
right side all of the courses will come
up here and uh also if you want to learn
how after
getting the uh
like after going through a particular
coursework where in which particular
fields can you apply the knowledge that
you gain or how you can answer a
particular research question applying
the knowledge that you gain from a
coursework we have various example
projects now to explore the example
projects click on the project tab and
then you'll have various example
projects and
we have classified it over here so if
you click on data science you'll be able
to just shortlist the exact project that
you would be interested to go through to
understand the application of the
coursework
so that was it about navigation on the
portal for the for various courses
uh and also now quickly let's have a
look
on the program page
now those who have successfully enrolled
for the program
they should have the badge of the
program now having the badge of the
program on your profile will make sure
that you are a part of this program page
now what do i mean by being a part of
this page if you scroll down you can see
that we have uh mentioned the details
for each and every session here the
schedule for each and every session has
been mentioned here
now as we have the very first session
today just after this session after a
few hours or so
you can see the recording of the session
here on the program page itself you can
go through the recording once again to
revisit the topics that we are going to
discuss today
also
along with each session you can see the
topics to be covered in the live session
now in the live session that we'll go
through that's what we understand and
also we have some coding lessons that
you have to go through and complete now
these coding lessons are actually the
lessons of the courses that i just
showed you our course one in our course
too so we have structured it in such a
manner that the mentor will be taking
you through the topics and then you need
to practice it yourself uh from these
lessons right
now once you go through these lessons
complete all the assignments and also
you uh go through the recording you need
to click on the complete session item
this complete session icon will get
activated once you have completed the
lessons and also gone through the
recording you need to click on the
complete session icon and do so for each
and every session um on or after the
session date
now by clicking on the complete session
icon you will be able to complete all
these sessions on the on the program
page and you will get your certificate
again in the profile section
so that were a few important things that
i wanted to discuss with the
participants before we actually get
started
uh now i'll uh hand over the stage to dr
raghav let's get started with today's
session
and uh today we will be discussing
about we just get started first of all
uh with r we will discuss about big data
and bioinformatics and also we learn to
use the code playground the inbuilt
console on the homicide learn portal and
learn how to load data in r
also we recommend uh
you all to please go through the very
first coursework on the portal that is
introduction to bioinformatics
for those who come from a
non-bioinformatics background this
particular coursework will help you get
started with bioinformatics as a field
and also help you understand why
bioinformatics is important like what is
the role of the field and uh how does it
help in translational health care like
what is its role in translational health
care it's a very short course work and
you will be able to just complete it
with a few words so that is also one of
your assignments for today
all right so that was it now uh if you
have any of um
the issues or if you face any in any
technical glitch then you can please let
me know i'm here in the session itself
you can let me know in the chat box
maybe you're after the session and i'll
be uh happy to help you
uh over to you dr rakov
[Music]
thank you thank you very much i mean
let's get started before sharing my
screen let me ask you how many of you
have had any sort of introduction to r
uh before i mean not that it is
mandatory that we should have but if you
have had any sort of any introduction to
r or um
using r then
give a yes or one in the chat box so
let's find way to share my screen
okay we have some few
inputs coming that's really good good
it's not a prerequisite just to get an
idea of how many of you have had some uh
some introduction to r
and and how many of you have had none so
that i can
plan how deep i should go and from where
should i start okay thank you very much
i think i get a general idea of of the
distribution thank you very much keep
keep keep coming so hello and welcome
everybody for the first session of the
program getting started with
bioinformatics in r today we will learn
about what constitutes a big data in the
field of bioinformatics
and we will learn about why a
programming environment like r is best
suited for studying this big data
analysis
and finally we will get an introduction
to our data types and how omix data can
be loaded into this environment for
further data exploration
so
as we start let's begin with what is
bioinformatics so if you are new to
bioinformatics as sonalika mentioned
go through the introduction to
bioinformatics course that is going to
help you with a lot of uh uh
yeah with lot of necessary uh knowledge
about uh
different topics that we are going to
deal with that we are going to discuss
uh with today and also throughout this
program
so it is a convergence of biology and
data that both are equally important as
we will see in next few slides and also
as we will see throughout this session
so who uses bioinformatics and
for whom is it for the answer might have
been something like 10 years ago the
answer might have been for statistician
computer scientists or engineers but
today the truth is that more and more
biologists and clinicians are expected
to understand handle and then analyze
their own data to succeed or to publish
in basic and translational research so
in fact
because of this change change the
biology itself is rapidly changing and
it's acquiring the character of data
science and what do i mean by that so
biology in today's era is is actually
can be analogous to data science
of biological data so where billions of
data points on genes proteins and other
molecules are compiled in large files
and systematically analyze to study so
analyzing such data will lead to more
knowledge and will lead to more
understanding about the living organisms
including human
living organisms that will help us
understand human health
in different biotechnological areas and
it will help us understand crops and
also it will help us understand
areas like metagenomics and
viruses infectious diseases and etcetera
so this influx of huge volume of data
and the development of associated
methodologies has completely changed the
biological research towards a
data-driven approach for uh for
research and asking questions so this
change has made bioinformatics for life
sciences as prominent as computers for
tech industries
so we spoke about big data and their
effort and their effect
in changing the phase of biology
and biological research so where is this
data coming from this field the whole
omics field is based on high throughput
technologies that will generate
billions and billions of data points on
genes proteins and other molecules that
characterize biological system and
phenomena we will have molecules that
characterizes the phenomics of the
phenomics of the cell the genomics of
the cell and we will have epigenetic
modifications and we can also have
transcriptomics data so these data are
compiled into repositories and these
repositories are available for many uh
for public general public to download
and analyze
so that they can be systematically
studied to understand interrogate and to
establish trends for many different
applications not only limited to biology
not only limited to clinical sciences
but many different applications in
general
so as i mentioned this is open for
public so is such data available
yes it is available and one such
repository is maintained by the national
center of biotechnology information
which has at its base a collection of
peer-reviewed articles biological data
sets and projects on various different
topics and various different data types
as you can see in the past several
decades this is this resource has been
growing exponentially and
and the data that is submitted has has
been yeah has been so rich so that the
analysis methods and analysis analyzed
data has not been able to catch up
so to give you a perspective there are
at least over 80 000 publicly available
data sets in just one part of ncbi
database called geo database which
stands for um gene expression omnibus
such data repositories contain datasets
on thousands of genes in each sample
with tens and hundreds tens and even
hundreds of samples per
okay
can you see my screen i think now it is
possible yeah how it is
so we discussed bioinformatics
or biology acquiring properties of data
science now let me give you a brief
overview of what data science is and how
it involves uh
how it studies different
data
so at its basic level data science
involves developing methods of recording
storing and analyzing data to
effectively extract useful information
so what do i mean by that so the goal of
data science is to gain insights and
knowledge from any type of data so the
data need not be of particular type that
the data can be unstructured the data
can be structured and data can be
semi-structured so what do i mean by
unstructured data so unscripted data is
what you would have to typically deal
with when you are prepared to
start with analyze analysis or when you
are prepared to start with
bioinformatics analysis to make it
useful
so to give you
an explanation how to convert or how to
go from unstructured data to a
structured data let me
give you an example so
if i ask you
if i ask
a poll or a question or survey
if i conduct a survey and ask you what
is your educational background you might
respond in multiple different ways for
example i am studying a particular
subject biochemistry or biotechnology
and you can tell i have a degree in
computer science i'm a graduate student
you can say i'm a research scientist
so
somebody like a human will easily
understand what each and every one of
these responses mean but if the data has
to be collected from let's say thousands
and hundred even hundreds of students it
would be very very hard for
for for a human to go over this and
summarize and
yeah
and summarize and compare students using
such responses which are unstructured so
instead we tend to structure our surveys
by replacing the actual information with
a short form or codes or categories
which we can easily analyze so as a
result of scale how many data points we
collect uh the need for i mean depending
upon the need for the structure
the data points will
the number of data points will change so
here we are interested in identifying or
we are interested in segregating the
background population or the survey
population based on only four different
data or four different types
so
if you need to take or if you need to
have an elaborate survey then the number
of data points and or the number or the
structure of the data keeps
growing
so so by collecting this data or by
forcing structure can actually reduce
the amount of information we collect so
how as you saw in the previous
category so instead of giving an
open-ended question like this if if i
force you into a structure
that is going to
not be applicable for many students some
of the students might not might not fall
into one of these categories so i don't
have a category to represent them even
including a category like others might
not give me necessary information so
what happens is oftentimes we collect
data in whatever format we we can and
then worry about structuring it or
organizing it later this happens as we
as we apply
different pre-processing techniques or
we perform
different
structuring of the data and
capturing what's inside this
unstructured data to categorize them
into
structure of our interest and arranging
data in a way where we can perform some
reliable statistical analysis
so
when we translate this structure and
such a data into a structured data and
this structure data will be
this structure data is what we aim to
use for analysis interpretation and
visualization so that it can easily be
shared so it can easily be interpreted
like this
so
same would be true for any kind of data
and it is absolutely true for big data
so big data has certain characteristics
that we have to keep in mind while
analysis like velocity variability and
volume to make sense of such data we
have to process it and prepare it for
analysis
so by by what do i mean by processing it
and preparing it for analysis so for
example to structure omics
data which is the primary form of data
that we will be dealing with in this
program and also in
learnomics platform as such so we need
to take the raw sequencing data that is
strings of letters that contain a t g
and c and to generate a data set or to
generate a matrix or generate a table of
continuous or categorical data so when
we generate this table we can
subject this table for further detail
analysis lot of statistical analysis and
etcetera so to do this we organize
processing steps in sequences that we
will refer to as pipelines that are
specific to
each type of or mix data for example if
the data is from genomics then we have a
specific
sequence of algorithms or specific
pipeline
that takes the genomics unstructured
data into structured data and similarly
if the sequence if the data is from
proteomics we follow a different set of
pipeline that will take this
unstructured proteomic data and convert
that into structured data so this
applies for all possible omics data
indeed it applies for all possible data
uh all sorts of data in general so the
aim of
using or the aim of
trying to employ different programming
environment
for any type of biological data to or to
any type of data is to get to a point
where we have
good quality structured data to begin
with so that is extremely important step
so to give you a perspective um
we have so much of unstructured data and
we have so little of structured data
that necessary for this conversion the
necessary for such an analysis keeps on
growing so we have not caught up yet and
because we have so much unstructured
data and
people and and there are ways to
there are ways to uh deposit only
unstructured data like when they when
people sequence and when researchers
sequence data when they acquire
sequencing data they they get the
biological uh
digital sequencing data which is
unstructured data and then they submit
it or they
deposit in the repositories for
everybody else to download and then
analyze and then get their own um
biological implications or find their
own biological
results from
so how to do this or there are different
ways as i mentioned to get go from
unstructured data to structure data we
will discuss few and how it is possible
in uh
in for example in the bioinformatics
platform or big data bioinformatics
platform that that we have in talbot
bioinfo platform so for example in in
the event of genomics data we always
start from raw first two files and then
we use a pipeline as i mentioned
called a dna variant calling pipeline
where we select specific algorithms that
will take the raw foster files and then
subject it into a sequence of analysis
methods and in the end we are going to
receive or we are going to um
get a table of
mutation or muta mutation information or
we will get a list of variants that can
be identified from the raw foster files
are raw unstructured data so this
mapping the whole process can either be
visualized using some visualization as i
mentioned here or the aim of this
visualization the name of this analysis
is to identify those places where our
sequence or the sequence for the sample
that we have recorded the data varies um
from the reference genome that we are
comparing our
biological data without comparing the
first q file data away so this
variance can be listed or it can indeed
be tabulated in something like a table
of somatic mutations on such a table
can be used for
basic and advanced statistical analysis
methods using r or python or any
programming language even spss and
matlab and anything that you are
comfortable with so basically the aim is
to go from whatever digital data that we
have into a table or data that resembles
a table of rows and columns
with
numerical or categorical information
that we can one can populate from the
data that we have recorded
so in this somatic mutation table what
we have in the
rows are
dna positions or genomic positions and
what what we have in the columns or
important column or the sonatic score or
the
mutability index for that specific
position so higher the score higher the
um
mutation rate for that spec in that
specific position and lower the score
lower the mutation rate for that
specific position so from where we can
get this table i have a question arti we
have to generate this table using a
pipeline or using some sort of sequence
of python analysis method that i have
mentioned
so if you want to get such table maybe
some publications which are dealing with
this type of analysis can actually
supplement this table or give this this
kind of table in the supplementary
information if not then most of the
raw data
we we can that we can acquire from the
ncbi database or repository can be
subjected to this analysis and this data
can be generated for each and every uh
different and biological sample
so let's yeah let's go through it yeah
yeah so for example
this mutational status can be often
matched to um
presence or absence of these mutations
for example when you are going to
analyze uh
when you are going to analyze and
interpret a tumor biology
you will find large scores or scores
higher scores for tumor sample and lower
scores for normal samples indicating
that accumulation of somatic mutation in
tumor samples and
a normal a mutation at normal rate for
adjacent normal issue samples so yeah
that is the biological relevance of this
data and another example of data that we
already know that we are familiar with
transcriptomics data which represents
the mrna expression and this
ident are analyzing or quantifying this
mrna expression is an excellent way to
analyze um
what is going on inside a cell by
observing active transcription of
protein coding genes so this is possible
as we know that the dna is transcribed
to rna and rna is translated into
protein but in this process not all of
the exons are actually used for
translating into protein some of them
are skipped and this data or this
information that we can get from
this information that we can get from
quantifying or analyzing the mrn
recording the mrnas of the cells in
specific situation so a typical analysis
pipeline for the analysis of
transcriptomic data will allow us to uh
oh it went too much too quickly so it
will allow us to uh clean the fasci
files or do the pre-processing and then
it will let us to map the tran
map the reads onto either genome or onto
transcriptome and then quantify these
mapped reads into a into a table of
expression quantification table and then
end the pipeline and
such a table will look like this and
you might obtain a table for example
that has all the sample names organized
in the columns and all the gene ids or
transcript ids organized in the rows and
the intersection will actually contain
the expression level that is quantified
for this specific gene at this specific
sample
so this is another form of structured
data that we can easily use to
understand the biological state of these
samples differently usually these
samples will have biological replicates
and thus our statistical power of
interpreting the difference between one
type of sample and the other type of
sample is increased and another type of
data that we will all see
in this program and also will generally
is
is using the same sequencing technique
but it offers completely a different
view of biological samples so in this
case we are not looking at
looking at a sample that contains one
type of genome but we are looking at a
sample that contains millions of
microorganisms and represents
represented by their respective genome
that are different from each other that
are very different from each other to
structure this data and or to organize
this so much of genomic information into
categories we can take genes that are
functionally related and genes that are
common to all the organisms and identify
their divergence or identify their
differences and identify the number of
microorganisms depending upon counting
this specific genes that is gene that is
shared by all types of
organisms so for example like the
ribosome which can be compared to a
database of its own sequences so such an
analysis is commonly referred to as 16s
ribosomal rna because we are actually
taking that one specific gene to
understand or to quantify the amount of
biological or
to quantify the amount of
what type of
biological organism present in the
sample and it's called sixteenish
amplicon data and this can be subjected
to a data to sequencing pipeline and
such a pipeline will actually
give you or help you in obtaining
proportions of taxonomic growth groups
across samples and
this can be used to understand abundance
of specific microorganisms that might be
linked to the phenotypic variation so
the basic type of structure data that
one can obtain from this
this case is also a table and this table
will contain lot of operational
taxonomical units across samples with
proportional abundance in each and every
cell so these otus are the taxonomical
variants or
taxonomical groups that can be linked by
guru kingdom phylum class order etc etc
and
these are the samples that will contain
their respective abundance level at this
number so these are the three different
types of uh for example yeah these are
the three different types of structured
data that we will be dealing with over
the course of this
program and
yeah
this we spoke about the
operational taxonomical unit that groups
the uh input uh that that groups the
sequences based on their um
similarity level into a different
pyramid of taxonomical order so
so far we have been talking with talking
about the structured data
that can that that can be generated from
three at least three different sources
so now let's take this structured data
and how can we
represent or how can we really how can
we
take this structured data and make a
programming environment like r store and
analyze this data and understand and
help us understand the patterns within
this data so to do this we have to make
use of uh different collections of data
types that one can find uh usually find
in r and also in python generally so um
i'm using this uh in a in a way where
you can apply this to r and also python
because they are very similar in this
case so a vector in this case is just a
collection of objects in in one
dimension and the matrix in this case is
a collection of objects
in two dimension and at least in two
dimensions right preferably or
specifically only numerical data a
vector can be a collection of different
types of data a matrix has to be a two
dimensional um it can be
three-dimensional also at least
two-dimensional collection of only
numerical data
are they an array can be
more than two-dimensional
in nature and they can contain again
they can contain
either
all all of numerical data or all of
different types of data but one of the
most interesting and one of the most
useful data type or object type that we
will be using is a data frame which is
essentially a table in its absolutely
natural form
so in our table as we mentioned if we
have to prepare a table that
that gives structure to some sort of
data that we have collected in that
table we will be inclined to
include
for example a character type that can
represent your name it will be it can
include
for example
numerical type that can represent your
height weight etc it can include for
example
a factor type or a categorical type like
your blood group which takes only a
specific set of variables not all
possible all possible variables it can
take something like date type like your
date of birth it can take something like
a logical type whether you whether you
are male or female that can be converted
into logical uh binary logical database
so this what you see is a collection of
different types of different data types
of different classes of data
that can be organized into one table and
such an organization preserved as such
will represent a data frame in r or in
python's language so we will be using
most of this data frame and we will load
all of these structured data that we
have been discussing in the previous
slides into a data frame and then we
will start our analysis from that so in
addition to this you will also find
lists which are which is just collection
of different types of data into uh into
an organized group so that you can
you can um
query them or you can access them
whenever you need to access it
so what can we do with such a
data structure data that is loaded as an
object in
environment like python or r so for
example you can run some
[Music]
transformation analysis you can run
[Music]
analysis on the distribution so that we
can understand uh what's the pattern of
the data and we can understand if there
is any specific correlation or if there
is any specific relation exist between
two features or two genes in the data so
if you want to identify whether gene two
and gene three are correlated we can
use this um scatter plot for gene two
and gene three in specific and then
identified uh identify their
relationship to each other so what is
fpkm fpkm is um is a normalization
applied to transcriptomics data which
refers to fragments per kilobase million
so when you count the mrna molecules
that are mapped onto different genes
then these absolute count can have
influences or can have biases due to the
length of the gene and the coverage
depth of the coverage yes it is one of
the normalization means and the depth of
the coverage that gene will actually
encounter so fpkm will uh will eradicate
or will actually account for that
difference in the um coverage due to the
length of the gene also due to the depth
of the coverage that does g that this
gene can
encounter so we can understand the data
further and use different visual
representation to spot technical noises
that is important to eliminate and also
to spot technical i mean to spot
specific signals that we have to
concentrate on to understand the
patterns in the data so all these
analysis we will perform in
in the upcoming sessions
so we can also extend this to uh more
biologically meaningful data analysis
and exploration like a heat map which
will give you a generic uh which will
give you a a general expression pattern
or different types of or different types
of samples that you have in your
different types of samples that you have
in your data set so we can further uh
extend this to much more advanced
statistical analysis like data mining
classification uh supervised
machine learning and unsupervised
machine learning to understand or to um
explore the relationship between the
features or genes
to understand to understand the generic
pattern that is present in our data so
that we can relate or we can correlate
this pattern with the biological nature
or the phenotypical characteristic of
the data so this will this is what we
are going to deal with in in
in this program so far so if you are
true with this let me quickly go through
go to the lessons and give you a demo of
how we are going to go about the uh go
about this um
these analysis methods and etc so if you
have any query uh please put that up in
the chat let me stop sharing my
powerpoint presentation and then get to
my
browser
so do you have any query so far please
mention that in the chat room
so let's get
where is my
this has to be it
can i mean please confirm you can see my
screen
and what is the screen that you see can
you see the loading in loading data in
our screen
yes
okay thank you very much so um
so this is this is one of the associated
lessons that you get
yeah that you get with uh with your uh
in your program page this is where i
took it from so these are the associated
lessons that we are going to discuss so
far
here so if you go to
introduction to r you will get an
introduction to what r is about and then
how to get r so how many of you have
installed r in your computer do you have
access to rstudio or r in your computer
please represent that i mean please let
me know in in the chat
yes that's perfect then if you have r in
your computer uh yeah please open up
this lesson both are in our studio
perfect then our studio is more related
so open up this specific lesson in your
our in your browser window you can
follow along as i uh
as we
explore this lesson
so the first yeah excellent so the first
uh
section is actually going to introduce
you to our as a as how to download and
how to uh install in
in
in your computer and how it is generally
useful for bioinformatics but let's
i'll let you go through this and then
skip next to getting started with r so
here you see we take this specific uh
example code which is a code to read a
table or which is a code to read a
structure table that we have been
discussing so far and then
into read this table into
so let's copy this
and then i'm going to go oh let me share
everything i think i have to share
everything so that you can see my
rstudio also
yeah i think you can check you can see
my screen confirm it
yes
yes thank you very much so
your r studio window will look like this
so uh this or the other way uh it will
look like this um
i have it organized it's tightly
differently uh so your console window
will look here let's do that sort of
organization
and
uh
console on the left console on the right
i should pan layout go there
is this cone okay here okay
okay this is how it is going to look
like for you
so what do you see here is
it supply yes what do you see here
is uh you will find this is the r
console where we are going to interact
with r in this window and r is going to
give us uh what is going to process from
this window and this is where you will
see
all the variables or objects that we are
going to load into r is going to be
displayed here and this is where you are
you are going to see
your plots you can see your plots here
that you are going to generate and you
can see
what is the current working directory
and what are the files available in the
current working directory yeah so
the
the file or the line that i just copied
had can be pasted onto
what we
see here as the
source window or source panel this is a
source panel and this is a console panel
so in the source panel it's like
it's like writing an r script where you
can write the r script and then execute
this r script line by line so it it
reads it tells we are going to use a
function read dot table and also it
tells you uh i have to use uh use a
specific path to find where to find this
specific file and also i have to use
and also have to mention several other
parameters that is going to describe the
data that i have
okay let's go back to the uh lesson and
let's see what the lesson tells us the
lesson is going to tell us uh give us an
uh give us a link to where to find this
specific file name well let's
see where is the file
associated file
okay it's not here let's get the file so
in order to get the file you can
actually come down
and take get a link from here so this
link if you open in in a tab or a new
tab is going to open up like this
so this is a structured table which is a
gene expression table and then we can
what we can do is we can copy this
as a
link address and i'm going to paste this
link in the chat window if you have
opened this you
can follow along you can copy this and
then you can go to your r studio
and then right between where to find
this
part right
you have to
delete this and then paste it
exactly in this position paste it so
this r can also read files from files
that are made to be available or made to
be accessed through internet so this is
a file that you can one can access from
internet so that's what we are going to
read so let's break this down right
let's break uh this read table or
loading this uh
and this table into our much uh a lot
like let's just read the table without
anything right read the read.table and
then
type this so i'm what what what am i
typing i'm just using the function
read.table and then specifying the um
specif specifying the table where to
find that specific table so if i execute
it wow my code runs it actually got
executed but what do i see i see an
on-screen output which
uh which is
i mean
on screen output of how r had actually
read this table i do not see any
variable or any object that is stored in
my object or variable window so to
access this information or to access
this table we have to store whatever we
executed right now into an object so
that we can keep retrieving that object
and wait make
or
use that object for
further statistical analysis so that is
what we are doing it here so r uses this
specific operator which looks like uh
which is a less than symbol followed by
a hyphen to redirect whatever you see as
an output of this specific function into
this specific or this object this object
will be a data frame and that is why it
is abbreviated into df so let's do that
and increase the complexity one by one
so let's do that
and then this is going to be read.table
at its absolute minimum and then
so in order to execute this you can
select all of this and then run
or you can keep the cursor at anywhere
on this line and then run so i am
keeping the cursor on this specific part
in this specific line and then i'm
running it so if you see carefully there
are two changes that happen so this line
got this line executed successfully and
r is not giving me any error and in
addition to that i am having one data or
one object that appear in my uh
environment page and this tells that
this object is 16 observation and 53
variables long so what do i mean by that
if i click
on this i will be able to visualize this
just like excel format it is not advised
it is not visibility to do that but for
small data set it is okay so what does
what do they mean 16 observation would
mean 16 rows and 53 variables would mean
53 or columns that is what it does it
means
but
if you see how our data is actually
visualized there is a
there is a difficulty or there is a
there is a disadvantage our data
actually has what we call as header
header is what we uh in our data that
specifies what each and every column
would mean so this column means id
column this column means normal like
column and this column would be normal
like column and this column would mean
vessel and etcetera etcetera but by
mentioning nothing about what our data
contains and how our data is organized
we have actually
encountered a problem where
the header is actually reading as one of
the lines and that is going to obscure
or that is going to
not uh be very helpful for us to perform
any statistical analysis on this
specific data type so let's correct that
by mentioning
one additional option or one additional
parameter which says header equals true
so that would generally mean uh we are
we have a header line in our data in our
input table so i run this again
so now
you immediately see since i run it and
since i have
put it or edited the same line and i
redirected the output to the same object
the object became 16 observation
interval instead of a 15 observation so
let's view this
now now it looks like little bit better
and the one of the okay let's compare
both uh let's do that um
so that you can understand so i am going
to rename this as df one and keep the
old one as df
so that we can do a side by side
comparison and then i am running the old
one first
df
and then i'm running the new one the df1
next
and then let's visualize both
so this is the visualization of df and
this is a visualization of df1
so what do you see what is the change
that you see
can anyone spot the change in the
numbers
did you get this part
did you get this yes did you try to
condition did you get this far
yes so what is the what is the change in
number that you see in the numbers
yes the object the observation has
changed from 16 to 15.
yeah the observation has changed from 16
to 15 but
if you see here
the zeros are just zeros and they are
left aligned
right and here you can see we have right
aligned and the zeros are have their
significant values so if you have worked
with excel you would know that anything
that is left aligned is a character or
it's a text format
so in spite of these values being
numbers since the first value is a text
all of these values are considered as
text only
so in this specific data set where we
mentioned the header uh where we we did
not properly describe our input tape so
in this
function where we describe the input
table properly
all of the numbers are written as
numbers
okay we can we can get
some more information regarding this i
will demonstrate this to you in the next
session where we can perform some
summary operations some statistical
operations on these numbers which for
which such a
detail or such a level of
description of the data is very helpful
so
this has this we cannot perform any
statistical analysis on this we cannot
calculate mean we cannot calculate sum
we cannot do anything in this way but
this it is possible to do that which is
our soul a which is our main aim
so what is the zeros in df1 mean so the
zeros in df1 mean
there is no expression for this specific
gene for at this specific sample
so that is what biologically this
specific this one means so gene two is
expressed at two point zero four time ah
zero four fpk m value for this specific
sample and similarly a gene two is
expressed or is not expressed at all in
the luminal sample so this is what zero
biologically means
so this so describing or describing the
um
uh
data becomes uh correctly becomes
extremely important so in addition to
this we have some more
somewhat parameters that will become
extremely important for us to move
forward for example what is the next
parameter that says the next parameter
is the one that says how
each of these columns are separated in
our input table so if you open the input
table in in any nodes or in any text
editor you can see that the columns are
separated
by a tab
delimited value so that is what this one
says so read dot table by default right
by default it assumes that um your data
is tab delimited and that is the reason
our data is uh read incorrectly if our
data is not dab delimited and if it is a
comma delimiter then there would be a
big mess in the data and that we will
not be observing these many different
columns in the data that is what it is
so
uh what else do we have here so we have
here row names equals 1. so let's
take this
use both of these
and
and go to df2
[Music]
and do this and see
what change does this actually
create in our data set
so if you uh run df2
so what changed what did it change here
the number of columns reduced from 53 to
52. so let's open up df2
which is here
let's put it here
so what happens here in df1 observe what
is what is
mentioned on the left this is the row
name or row number or the
quantity or the identity with which this
row can be uh
called or this row can be identified
with or this row can be selected for
further statistical or further different
analysis
now by including the flag or including
the parameter row dot names equals 1
right equals 1
then what have we done we have changed
the first column into row name so the
first column is now known as gene one
column gene one row uh before yeah sorry
the first column will actually replace
the row names and the first row instead
of being known as one two three four
five six in these two data frames it
will be known as gene one gene two gene
three gene four gene five gene six in
these ones so that is what it is
so that is that is why it is very
important and the next one more one more
uh
phase
this is this will be important in the
case if you have for example computing
row names or completing column names if
you have that in this data we do not
have that if you have that r is going to
throw you an error say that you have
duplicate row names or you have
duplicate column names i cannot load
this properly you have error in your
data so having this specific
parameter will actually turn down the
check and then let r load the data in
whatever format it is so that it is um
it is
reading properly
so that is that is how that is how you
can
load a data or import a data into
into our code
since we are going little bit overboard
this we covered so this is not
restricted to a dot txt file and this is
not restricted to columns that are
separated by comma so this is the same
logic and i want you to go through this
uh associated lesson where we have
multiple different options where when
you use option like semicolon then you
are using a
using a file with a semicolon separated
format
but more
for example
a related format or more
relatable
format used format is csv format comma
separated file format which we can
use ah for further for these analysis so
ah let's see if we have a csv format
in this one
so
i have demonstrated you how to take this
code put it into our studio and try to
run it but you don't if you do not have
our studio or you can if you do not want
to change to a different environment you
can do it here itself this is an r
console we give it to you
for you to practice whatever you have
learned from your in this section so in
this section as i mentioned you are
going to go through um these functions
or these different codes that will help
you
import on viewer text file into r so
that is what it does and this tells you
how each and every different
parameters
actually
correspond to different options as i had
actually mentioned and how they describe
our data in its entirety so that we can
load the data in it in the in the form
that we want to load in and to perform a
necessary
to perform necessary analysis like this
we will come to visualization in in next
lesson or the next to next session
because right now we are running out of
time and i quickly want to tell you
how to use or how to uh
use this console for your analysis so um
read through this specific line it says
here we deleted some part of the syntax
of the code and you need to complete
those parts so that this r code can run
successfully so if i run just like this
it's going to throw you an error
and yeah
that is it it says it cannot open
something and it's so it's going to
throw an error so what is missing the
file is the link for the file is missing
which is what you can find here you can
copy link
and then go you go to this specific book
but and then update that with the link
and then
try to run it
if you try to run it it will
give you different error okay why does
it give me different error and it also
tells success in running the code but
the answer is incomplete but if you had
run through that if you have gone
through the
data if you've gone through the lesson
it will tell you there is an important
function called dim or dimension short
form for dimension dim function which
will tell you how wide and how long your
data set is so let's run this
it's now it says success running code
the answer is correct because it just
keeps on updating so we will
clear the con clear the console
like this and then run it again
so now it says
this data frame that we loaded has 15
columns sorry 15 rows and 52 columns
which is what we saw in
rstudio here so the same dim function
can also be used here
to identify or to see uh to verify what
is the dimension of this specific data
frame so it is
like this here 15 and 52 it's always
rows first and column second so the
dimension of this data frame is 15 rows
and 52 columns so that is
so you can practice that in in here if
you go to next
section next section deals with how to
visualize box plot so all of the
incomplete code that you will find in
this imported data so in this uh
test your skills are execute in
executing our code can be found in this
uh
learn the code section so if you go to
learn the code or go through the learn
the code section
carefully then you will be able to
relate to
this
you'll be able to relate to
the necessary codes or necessary
completion of the course that is
absolutely required for you to
run this call so this is so far this is
what i will cover in this
in this class and then for the next few
classes we will
go through we will discuss um
after loading the data how to perform
some
really starting sample statistical
analysis and summary analysis and how to
visualize the data in the form of box
plot or scatter plot or a heat map
etcetera so that we can understand we
can understand uh the general pattern
that
that one can identify from the day so if
you have any questions until now please
let me know um if not yeah
i see in the chat that some of you said
it is not for yeah you did not get uh
get to the same stage as as what i got
so
maybe if you go again and go through the
associated resources and it will be
helpful for you to
recreate or be helpful for you to
execute the code in
rstudio or you can copy it and execute
the code in the
in the
try it for yourself section just below
the uh learn the code section
so
yeah
thank you very much for now and if you
have any other queries yeah and and let
me know and i hope to see you all of you
in the
future session so well we are going to
not only just load this data we are
going to
do some lot of summary about this data
we are going to
print out summary statistics and we are
going to
see the distribution of the data in
terms of heat map
density plot
histogram
box plots everything pca and everything
so that we can learn more about the data
which is above which is what our aims
if we have no no more queries then i can
pass this on to sunalika
i think there are some questions about
where to find the coding of the session
and where to find sessions slides for
the sessions i think i can
let you know
yes so the registered participants will
be getting the recording of the sessions
rt i don't think that you have enrolled
yet
so i'll just quickly take you through
the program page so that you can proceed
with the your program enrollment to get
the access to the recording and also the
other sessions
so to like today we had the first
session and i thought that we can write
our
registrations as well so that you know
how these sessions would be conducted it
was just an introductory session just to
get you started and we'll dig more deep
into the details of the topics and other
sessions
so now i'm just going to give you a
quick
demo sort of thing to tell you how you
can register yourself for the program
so here is the link to the program
in the chat
and those who are interested to enroll
for this particular program can pick up
any of these three subscription levels
beginner intermediate or advanced
and
get started with the program so the
beginner level you'll be a part of such
sessions and in the intermediate level
you will get um the access to your
environment sessions in addition to such
sessions and in the advanced level you
will get some extra time around a month
or so to work on your research proposal
and get started with your research
project
right so these are the three uh
differences in uh these three
subscription levels and if you are
interested to be a beginner intimidator
advanced that's your wish and you can
get started
uh yes the class was recorded and we'll
be sharing the link of the recording
with the registered participants lisa
and
luis
all right so now i think we are all set
to get started with another session on
python
so uh i think the specific participants
of python will be joining in somewhere
and
so we discussed about uh it was a
wonderful session and i hope now you
have a sense of various types of uh
mixed data types and
why do we need to analyze it what type
of data do we get in these different
sorts of fields and today we just
learned about how to load data and uh
just work with data
in uh like got to know about some a few
concepts that that would help you
and in the next sessions we are going to
discuss about statistical analysis and
visualizations as well
now let's get started with python and
again the same thing here is the link to
the program page for
uh getting started
with bioinformatics in python
on the page you can see that we have all
the sessions scheduled
and you will be able to look at the
session recording again on the program
page itself and the access to the
program page is given only to the
registered participants i'm repeating it
just to make sure so that you know who
all will have the access to it
and also then you have the resources
that you need to go through as a part of
each and every session so today we
discussed about
uh just getting started with our
dr raghav took us through the 11th
lesson in the bytes in the molecules uh
coursework to get you started you need
to complete that and also introduction
to bioinformatics similarly for our
today will be complete including data
and data visualization lessons as a part
of the very first uh session
after the session is over i'll put up
the recording and also you can revisit
the recording and click on the complete
session icon once you have watched the
recording completed the sessions
so that was about getting started with
python now uh i would like to pass it on
to dr raghav to
help us get started with uh python
so before going forward can i can ask
from the participants do we have any new
participant for participants for uh for
python
or if you are the same ones uh if you
already all of you
who are present here i will have speed
present for the uh our session then we
can quickly go straight to python
session in terms of all the same
introduction that i have
yeah planned for the uh
uh i think most of them are uh
the same
and also more participants are going to
join us and those who will be joining us
they can go through uh
for the understanding of big data and
various types of honesty
recording itself from the very beginning
and you can i think get started with
python directly what do you think about
it
i mean if that is the case then we can
you know we can continue with some more
uh
some more of our and then include python
also so that those whether it completes
the session uh we can show them some
visualization we can show them how to
retrieve the data
and then continue if that is the case
and if we do not have any new
participants so we can we can hear from
the participants themselves
so how many of you participants are here
for the we are here for the python
session only so how many of you have
joined only in last 10 minutes can you
please give me a yes or one
in
in the chat box
i think most of them have already been
here from the our session if that is the
case then that is excellence and then we
will continue for the our session for
another 10 minutes or 15 minutes and
then go to python how similar
data
loading can be done for python also okay
will that will that fill that work for
work for you
i think that will be good yeah because
if the if most of the participants are
saying then they can
they can access the
introduction to omix data
similarly here okay let's continue
in that case that then that's excellent
so let me share my screen again
so i showed you until now how to load a
r file okay i have a chat how to yeah
how to load
a data table into r as a data frame and
then
how to use a different parameters so
that we describe the data frame describe
our data table to its fullest and then
get extract a lot of information from
the data frame so what do i mean by that
let's go back to the rstudio and if you
are following along please keep your r
studio also
handy so now
we saw that using different
setting parameter settings we can
describe the data
in a way
how we want it and uh
once this is done properly once this is
done appropriately and then we take that
specific appropriate data frame and then
we can subject to multiple different
analysis so i showed you to demonstrate
you the difference between these three
data frames i just clicked on this data
frame and and then viewed their
[Music]
view on on here in the uh source panel
or in the uh source we are in the view
panel or source panel but
this is not going to be possible or this
is not going to be
efficient this is not an efficient way
of displaying or
skinning or actually getting an
introduction to your
data frame because
most of the time when we are going to
deal with data frames or tables at the
size of thousands and thousands of rows
and hundreds and hundreds of columns
this line or this mode of viewing and
exploring the data frame or object will
actually slow your computer down will
make your r run inefficiently so
so in order to do that we can start with
uh
simply typing the
name of the data frame for example df2
and then executing it if you do that so
that is going to execute
uh that is going to make the all of the
data frame um visible or it's going to
type what's going to make all the data
frame um
yeah print all the data frame on the
onscreen window so this is not going to
be useful for you and
for this data frame which has only 16
observation and only 50 to 16 rows for
52 columns it was possible for me to
scroll up and then check where the
beginning and how it looks like but for
most of the cases this is not going to
be very very informative for you because
going to keep running for thousands and
thousands of rows and
this is not a way this is not a good way
or efficient way to explore your table
data type so what is a good way to
export your data so let's use a function
called head
head will actually
take in any
variable or any object into its uh as an
input it's a function that is going to
print only first few lines of your first
few rows of your object the object in
this case is the data frame that we have
loaded with our tape so if i execute
head see what happens it is going to
give you what's going to show you or
display only first six
rows of your data frame
and even then i have to scroll something
like
multiple
times because i have all the columns
head is generally going to display all
the columns and only first six or five
rows depending upon the setting that you
have said most of the time by default at
6 so
how to get
get around this displaying of all the
columns in order to do that we have to
make use of
how
we can refer or how we can refer to
different columns and different rows of
a data frame in r
so um
if you can follow along and if you can
make this execute this in your r studio
please go ahead and if you yeah i am
following the chat if you have any
difficulties please let me know
now
we know that data frame is a collection
of rows and columns and of different
so how to access for example first row
only the first row or how to access only
the first column
so that can be done by um
indexing or what we call in our language
is indexing the data frame so or by
exactly mentioning or specifying which
which row or which column that we are
going to access or that we want to
take from
this specific data so that can be
done by using the square bracket so r
has a
has this feature or not r studio has
this feature if you open a square
bracket it will close all by its own
right in the inside the square bracket
as i always mentioned it it's always
beginning i mean the first uh index is
always row followed by the second index
is always column so what is the first
index here
it's a row so if i want to
display the first row of my data frame i
type 1 and then
if i run this what will happen can
anybody guess
can anybody guess will this code be
successful
yes or no simple will this code be
successful
yes
you can type let's try that
let's try that let's run this
yes it is successful because sorry i
have to type df1 df2
f2
of 1
yes it is successful because of the way
how r is going to treat your data so by
default it is going to assume that you
are mentioning a column of this data
frame if i want to have the row of this
data frame i have to mention
row
comma right it's always row comma column
so if i have to take the row of the data
frame i have to mention i want to take
the first row of the data frame and i
want to print all the columns of the
data frame and hence i have
kept it as or
left it as empty or left it as
unmentioned or unspecified in the column
place so if i run this specific
yes in this specific code it is going to
give me the first row
in multiple yeah display rows first row
and all of their columns if we go to the
display you can see that the first row
which is named by gene 1 is getting this
page so it's zero zero point four five
four zero one three that is that is what
is getting displayed this is how we can
call for specific
for example
if you don't want to use this confusing
uh
way of naming of indexing of column then
we can usually you we can use
df2
similar to what i have mentioned here we
can leave a blank for the row and we can
mention the first column
sorry and then if you run this specific
oh it's going to give me all of this
in a
list format or in a format where you
where it is giving and you observe the
difference between the format and this
format is like a example data frame
format right
this format is like a list format right
just printing all the values one after
the other
both these formats will have their place
but in general we will prefer indexing
like this or selecting specific rows or
specific columns like this
like okay if i have to mention more than
one row if i have to mention more than
one row or more than one column how do i
do so since
in our data set the interesting bits or
the samples
let's take the interesting samples like
um
rows are also interesting genes are also
interesting but we are generally
more um
inclined to understanding the sample
distribution so we will take uh or we
will actually
try to fetch or try to display first two
columns of this data frame df2 so how do
i do that so you can do that by
using the sequence operator which takes
a colon in between so
one two two will mean let's see what
what it does one to two will generally
mean just mention one and two so if i
type one to ten
it's going to take can you see that one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten so this is a sequence operator so
one two from one to two it doesn't have
to start with one i can start it five to
seven so it says five six seven so but
it cannot um
we cannot go in reverse i think yeah or
you can also go into first so i was
wrong so yes uh so you can use one to
two in this case and then run it we are
going to get both
uh first first sample and the second
sample
as our subset or as our
selection
such selection methods will become
extremely important because when we want
to
select only specific samples for further
analysis if i want to check only
specific samples for further analysis
this is how i will do and if i want to
check only let's say first to 10 genes
of all the samples and this is how i
will do 1 to 10
comma and everything and if i run this
this is how i will do see that i am
getting first to 10 rows or first 10
genes of all the columns or of all the
samples so what if i want to take first
10 rows and only first or two columns so
i can combine these two
df2
one to ten comma
one two two so this is what if i run
this so i'm getting first ten rows and
first two columns of these two
so this is how you can index or you can
mention with the numbers what are the
different columns and what are the
different rows that you have to or that
you want to ah
mention or that you want to subset from
your sample uh from your data framing
so this is about
exploring the data frame in the um in
the environment of r so we already had
an introduction to head and we already
had such a dim dimension output so dim
is just nothing but it's a short form
for dimension and that is going to give
you the dimension of your data frame
so it says this data frame is 15 rows
and long and 52 columns y so that is
what it's going to be so how many of you
since we are we are also going to deal
with python i want to tell one
very important difference between r and
python so if you see here
in order to query or in order to fetch
the first row or first column of the
data frame i used the number
one i use the number one that is rs
convention
all the index or all the arrays matrix
vectors everything starts from one in r
but this is not true for most of the
programming languages as for python it
will start from zero
okay
one easy way to
remember this is how many of you are
from u.s
in the u.s we do not refer to the
floor at the level of the ground as a
separate zero or ground floor we start
with the floor one floor one would mean
floor that is at the ground level for
the united states
that is ours convention
in python which follows something like
british or which follows something like
british occupied other colonies where we
have a separate floor or zeroth floor
for the floor that is at the ground
level so it's zero it always starts with
zero so for the same indexing that we
are going to do for the pythons in the
pythons demonstration we will start with
zero so the first
row will be indexed by zero number in
python so this is one important
difference that you will have to uh
remember and another one this operator
is specific to r which takes whatever is
on this side of the operator and assigns
that to this side of the operator
so this side of the operator can only be
an object or name of the object so this
side of the operator has to
give or has to result in some sort of
screen output so it will take this
output and then redirects it to this
specific operator so this is also um
very unique to r
this can also go in the other direction
also but we we don't want you to con
confuse so we just stick to this this is
equivalent to
this one equals
pf 2
equals r below this one will also give
you the same result but since this equal
to operator is used for other purposes
in ah so r has a specifically different
operator for this redirection and
assigning um whatever is on the output
to a different
object
so this is what i wanted to show you so
uh
in the associated lessons you will also
find some um
this for a box plot
so
you will see that so if i
type box plot let's try that
of df2
and see what happens if i run this code
and what happens to my r studio in this
code
so i am going to get a box plot in this
plot viewer can you all see my plot
viewer but there's a small box plot that
that i have generated so let's zoom in
if you zoom in it's good yeah it's going
to show you in brig so we will learn
more about how to change something like
this no
can you you know can you not see this
screen michael
michael is having difficulties in this
can yeah can you confirm that you can
see this screen where i have taken this
box plot and and made it a little bit
big here in the cloud zone
okay thank you very much so yeah so we
will learn more about how to make this
plot look better and more informative
in the terms of populating it with lot
of different
sample names and coloring it accordingly
and then transforming the scale to log
etc etc
excellent very good amount so um
in this one so for now we will leave it
this way so do you also all of you also
remember the difference between df these
three data frames that i was talking to
you about
and specifically at the beginning of the
session i was talking to you about
this data frame which had or which did
not
represent our table properly and
considers all these numbers to be
characters so how can we check that this
is one way to check that if you use df
instead of tf2 i urge all of you to try
that
bf and let's run this what does it say
yeah
so what does r say
congratulations to all of us we
encountered our first error in our
programming language so nobody can
escape encountering error but what does
it say
it says
non-numeric argument to binary operator
so it cannot deal with non-numeric
argument in in spite of the more in
spite of most of the data frame or most
of the data set having numbers it starts
with or the first data or first entry of
this column
or of every column is a character all of
these numbers are treated as characters
and hence box plot cannot be
cannot deal with character data box plot
has to deal with box plot is an analysis
that takes a numerical input so that's
what r is telling you about
so now that we have extracted data from
df2 where does the original data go no
it is not lost we have just
extracted it here no right so we have
not just like how we did for the first
read dot table function we have just
made it display on the table on the
on-screen output if you want to say for
example this subsetted data set into
something
new or something
some other object so we have to
specifically do that so let's do that so
that's a good point that great brought
that up so let's do that since we are
successful in uh identifying our
interested subsection of the data frame
so that data frame i have a habit of
having the parent data frame followed by
the underscore and
whatever modifications i do so i started
with df2 and then i left with something
that is small so s so that takes
whatever output
yes exactly that takes whatever output
this is so df2
1 to 10
comma
1 to 2. so if you execute this
so that is executed and you see here we
have 10 observation and 2 variables or
10 rows and 2 columns that is what we
observe here in this specific one and
yeah
yeah so the both the data survives the
data 2 df2
from which we have substituted this also
x's and df 2s
for
which i mean where we have taken this
subsetted data and then
[Music]
assigned it to gs2 also x so if you take
this this is what it looks like and
bf2 of course here so let's put it here
so df2 is a whole data set that also
survives and df2 s is a data set that
also survives so um until or unless
explicitly i mentioned to delete ds2 df2
or i reassign something into the same
name
whatever once loaded will not disappear
so it will only disappear if your r
session
gets rebooted or if your r session quits
or something like that whatever once
loaded will stay here as long as you
quit the session or end the session
i hope yeah i hope that is
that is more informative and if yes then
we can move on to python how python's
way of dealing with uh this data table
excellent thank you very much
so let me stop my share for our studio
and get it get your python lessons in
order
what is this okay
okay let me show my screen
okay i have to share everything that's
okay
so how many of you have uh
are using windows machine
some of yes yes some of you might use
linux and some of you might use
macintosh or mac machines so
yeah
for people who are using mac machines
python is going to come pre-installed in
their computer only the python is going
to come pre-installed and not the um
interactive development environment as
we would like to call the r studio that
i have described you that i have been
using
to
show you how
how r can be run in a very user friendly
environment is called ide interactive
development environment so for for many
of these coding languages we have to use
some sort of ide so that our job becomes
easier because most of the time we are
using r and python for
visualization purposes so
in the native r and python consoles
cannot produce a visualization output on
screen so that is why we have to resort
to this ide there are several ids
available for r and python and for r the
most
used
ide is
r studio
yes sure sure
yeah you can do that yes so our studio
is what
you you will most of us will use to run
r in a user-friendly environment and for
python we have several of uh at least
three different ways in which python can
be uh
interactively used or uh interactive
development development environment of
python can be used so one way is by by
using uh
visual studio python or visual studio
called code for python where you can uh
try to uh
download vs code and then launch it then
you will have you'll have a very uh user
user-friendly mode of running python
another way is to use konda anaconda or
coda libraries where it is going to
install a set of
interactive develop development
environment for not only for python
for r and for other uh different um
uh coding environments in your computer
so that is going to be big and this
kunda is going to help be helpful for
many people so because it is going to
install its own version of python and r
which you can manage it easily so that
you can check it out but one of the
easiest way to run python is using a
jupyter notebook that is online that is
available online in google collab format
so that is going to look like this
if ever if you have google
account you can use or you can leverage
google's uh
yeah resources like google collab or
co-laboratory
which is a python notebook where you can
run
this python's code python codes on the
google co-lab in interactive method so
that you can also do and or you can
follow along the pythons um
sections or python's
codes here in the load learn the code
section where i took it from your
associated or learning resources in the
um
in your
program page so this is where data
visualization and loading lessons for
python is where i took this specific
lesson from let's see
i will share this lesson with you in the
chat room so you can again open it for
you
okay somebody asked which one would be
better if we want to use offline
which one would be better if you want to
use offline um anaconda or konda
libraries are going to be bloated up is
going to be little bit big so if you
have some space you can use specific
condas or if you want to use only python
and some development environment for
python then pi
and you are mostly in windows
machines so install python as a
standalone and visual studio
as an ide for python that is going to be
sufficient for you that's going to
helpful that's going to do all the job
that you need and
if you have space and if you have much
more freedom or much more
not freedom uh much more organized uh
way of dealing with libraries and
packages and all of these installed uh
libraries then koda is the one that we
want to check
let's see i mean i'm also not sure if
i think i've seen this kunda
let's check
kind of yeah
yes it is available it should be
available for windows yes
yeah so this is docs anaconda so
anaconda install for windows is what you
want to check and this is how you can
install it for windows and get the
necessary this way so it's going to be a
little bit bloated but
it is going to be very very helpful uh
this is going to anaconda uh is going to
install you a separate ide for python
and it is also going to install you
something like jupyter notebook for
python where you can run python from
your computer on windows or not windows
on the web browser environment like just
like exactly like google collab but you
can use it for offline and you can use
it for your own
from your own computer resources so that
is that is one of the best way to
run python um it it involves letting
yeah exactly yeah
vs code is also better it's very simple
but um konda installation and setting up
requires a little bit of finesse to make
it work but if you yeah if you are uh if
you if you have
if you know or if you can do a little
bit of uh
modifying here and there and
understanding how things are getting
installed in your computer then konda is
going to be worth the dimension okay
let's go to this one so this is going to
deal with only visual code and this
python collaboratory notebook so how to
how to access this python cola um you
can actually
let's
[Music]
yeah okay loading
at this
okay
reconnect
so if you go to google
and type
in google
then it will give you
it will give you this welcome to google
collaboratory so it is just
you can click and then you can go to
collab.research.google.com and then the
collab notebook
let me get to the link and then share it
with you i think that should be a very
easy link
yes okay it's it's actually telling me
that i have several of the collab
notebooks available so
new note
and let's get the link from here
yes i got it there
yes
i think this is what we want okay
copy and you can use this for python's
uh
this and then
so this is you can generally go through
what this is and
oh they also give you some example codes
also that's also very good so let's deal
with let's go to the lesson and say what
and and see what the lesson deals with
so the lesson should actually tell you
what are the different ways you can
access or you can run python in your
computer and then again we start with
learning the code so for most of the
purposes it's going to be same like we
have
numerical matrices just like how we have
a numerical metrics for pyth for r and
we have a data frame just like how we
had data frame for r and we have
different
packages are modules that we have to
import in uh in for example in python's
environment in r also we might have to
load some specific libraries if we have
to perform the some specific uh
functions that
that is developed only for that library
so
more on this different libraries and
different functions and pack and
usage of different codes related to
specific to those libraries we will deal
with the upcoming sessions for r but you
cannot um work with python without
loading or without importing or
importing at least necessary packages so
all of the python code starts with at
least couple of packages like
we want to import the pandas package
which is defining how a data frame is
going to be defined or used and we want
to import something like numpy package
which is going to define how matrices
and different matrix operations are
going to be
used so
again we know what is matrix and the
matrix is a collection of
numerical objects that is in columns and
rows and pandas is a collection of a
different
date of data classes or objects of
different data types in a tabular format
so
how to do that we have to import the
package has some package so that we can
call np
to mention specific uh what do they call
as attributes or specific functions that
are uh defined in numpy library so
let's open up this
google collab it's all very this for me
let's open up a new notebook
so that it's new
yeah this is
this is how you will see so this i think
it's better if you can open this
specific notebook in python let it load
yes so this is what you will see so
let's take this and put it in the chat
box share box
where does the chat box
oh it's there
okay so this is what you will see
let's take this import
import
numpy as np and then import um
[Music]
pandas as pd
so you have to run this how do you run
this uh first you have to connect it so
everywhere you see this connect click to
connect so you connect it and wait for
this to allocate the memory resources
and allocate the resources and then
perform this connecting this thing uh
perform the connection yes and then we
have our own chrome app
ready to
be
explored and work with so you run this
if you run this what are you going to
get
you're not going to get any output but
you're going to get a tick mark that
says this
code is successful then let's take open
up another text or code so text is going
to give you
a window where you can type the text
right like this
okay this is
this code got
created so this is the text that we have
okay this is situation that we had
let's open up a text window
this is a text
okay let's click outside
this is what it will look like
so we can click another code window
after this so this is what is so you can
document your progress or document your
process of
running through this codes
as as you vision so that you can share
it with your your your peers so this
will be extremely helpful in sharing our
course so if you yeah if you go here in
the pythons or in the python
then again we will load this load this
uh object into python so again it's
simple
just like read the dot table function in
r we have a function here that says read
underscore table and we will need a
file name for this or we will need a
path for this one
so let's copy all of this
and see what do we have here
so if you are
walking along or working along with me
so do that we had the link for this in
the in the same uh
one that i shared with you or you can
take it from
down here somewhere down here and try it
yourself section that can also you can
take or let me uh get this from
instead of using some specific or some
generic output let's take more relevant
biological data which i i showed you to
describe
which i showed you to describe it
which i described you in our scoring
session
let's take this one
and
go there
are you following along
yes here
okay
so if you
execute this it's going to load execute
and then it says execution successful so
similarly just like
r we saw we already saw we have to load
this or we have to run this
input or we have to run this function
and then assign it to a object to an
object and the object here is again a
data frame so how do we know that is a
data frame it's probably it's it's
mainly um
by default it's a data frame in r but in
python since we are calling the read
underscore table from pandas library
it's a data frame pandas defines a
library so it's a data set so you can
type df to actually uh
show first few lines or show the uh
this of
show the
contents of this data frame it's going
to show it like this and it's going to
be similar
it's 15 rows and 53 columns exactly like
that but we see some changes what is the
change that you see that is not that
that you do not see in the
r or
environment do you remember when we run
this specific code in rs environment
r had a default uh situation where the
first line is not treated as a header it
is treated as part of the table itself
do you all remember that
yes
but in python that is changed so python
is little bit more user friendly as it
actually assumes that you have a header
information uh in the first
row and it takes that header information
for that and it also assumes that
your table is
tab delimited and etc etc so python is
yeah in that way python is more
intuitive and user friendly in the case
but you can also read in using the same
separator function you can also read it
read the
other
delimited files if if your file is comma
separated or comma delimited we can use
comma delimited also but we have to use
the separator which is exactly the same
in our
sep
equals
tab okay
but
what if our data set does not have a
header so again just like what we had in
r our data set here has a header so it
does not matter so what if our data set
does not have a header so in that case
you have to mention again the
same flag but instead of true or false
you have to mention it as zero so if you
do that and run it
then it's going to run
and it is going to complete and if you
run the df
okay now okay
why is this not working
suddenly it started to tell me that a
header equals zero
twice
yeah for some reasons it's not working
okay
let's try fast
false is not the
type
okay loading data i actually had this
somewhere
okay let's leave it that way i don't
know why it is not working if a header
is
mentioned as zero let's say one
yeah okay
okay it says header equals zero okay
that's not the case enter equals okay
header equals zero is not the case uh i
don't know what is the option for no
header that should be an option for no
header but uh yeah
we will leave it that way i will find
out and tell you in the next class i
also have to find out
okay so
so in unlike r
python is more user friendly and
intuitive where you see that in if you
type the data frame in its entirety or
it's going to keep on printing
everything until it stops but python
doesn't do that it runs for first few
rows and then
it takes a
an extension operator or tells you that
there are more information here and then
gives you last few columns also so so
you get a
decent understanding of the size of the
data frame so ah this is how it is again
in python's case let's go to the lesson
you can modify this separator to load a
comma separated format and also you can
load also
excel file so read underscore excel can
read excel file but usually this is not
recommended because we will do multiple
different
operations and multiple different
changes in the excel file and reading it
from excel file is not recommended if
you get hold of an excel file you can
open the excel file and save it as a tab
delimiter text format or comma separated
file format and then you can use it for
your
input
so
again
to check how big this data frame is we
can use
uh the function that says not dimension
but that says shape
it says
shape but how do we call that a specific
function we call that specific function
by typing the name of the data frame
that you want to call and then
mentioning a dot and then followed by
shape of
operator and if you type like this
it's going to throw you an error because
you should not
yeah
so you give only shape not shape of
operator only shape and it's going to
give you how big you are um
this is how big your
rows how many how many rows you have and
how wide your data frame is that is what
you are going to get and um
what else do we have here
sorry
you can also use something like
data type so uh
let's see what this specific code does
to our data frame
you can copy this
and then execute it
in the next collab
ok it actually gives you
something like
the
type of
different
columns that you have in your data frame
so it identifies each and every column
to be this data type this will be very
very helpful in the case if you have
lots and lots of columns and if any one
of those columns does not have a
starting number as starting value or
first value as number that's what we saw
right and when we saw the first value is
not a number the whole column is
considered a character so we don't want
such as such as such a problem for our
data frame because we want to perform
statistical operations and statistical
functions statistical analysis to our
data frame so we don't we don't want
that so
this is one of the way where you can
check a similar function also exists in
r which is a structure function if you
are interested i can go there and show
you how this function works in r
ah
let's compare that in r it's
the data types function is actually
given by
structure of
bf2
then if i
run this
it's going to okay not structure
things summer str
yes
yes str of this one so it's going to
give you what each and every
uh column is right it says a data frame
of a plane observation 42 variables and
it has so many different columns a
number and all of these are number
etcetera but it is mentioned as float in
in python's case so that is how we are
going to refer others how we are going
to find out how uh what are the
different uh
types of um
data types of columns that we have so
this is one way where we can
identify if any one of these data data
types or columns are not properly ready
so uh so let's see what do we have next
in this data let's try this you
ourselves in the try it yourself column
if you are following me let's open this
in uh in
in the
this lesson i think i shared this lesson
because this lesson or try it yourself
section in python is organized little
bit differently because of the console
then it is in r so in python you first
have to
run or you first have to import the
packages
first i have to import the packages and
this is how it is again
we have deleted some portions of syntax
so that you can practice inputting these
packages if you run as it is it is going
to throw you an error saying
unknown indentation error unknown line
so in python it is
very important for indentation okay we
can worry about intonation later but now
i am going to type complete the syntax
done this
success running code and access why is
the answer incorrect
maybe i have not uh
cleared this sample okay that's why
maybe run now yes success is running
code the answer is correct so i have
successfully imported pandas and numpy
as my pdm
so now in python
in order to
load up or in order to take a file and
load it into python's console what you
have to do is not it's the simple copy
and paste the link is not sufficient we
have to download this file like save
link cash and then download it into your
specific folder and then drop the file
into this specific part so that
this
can
the console can actually read the file
so i have already downloaded this
biological height dataset dot txt which
is
given here and then i'm going to
take that and
where did it go
yes here okay
let's close this and open our new one so
that it's easy for us to
make it small
there's no way to hide this all word
height rotating midi controls yes that's
what i want okay
so i wanted where is this i wanted this
one to be in
[Music]
somewhere where i can access
yes sessions and demo okay so this is
the data set that we are dealing with
let's take it and put it in uh
drag it it's not letting me do it
drag it and
drop a file here
and it is yes it is loaded and then
let's see some portions of this sample
is some portions of this is
not complete you can see that by running
and it is going to throw us some error
most likely
why it has not done it
maybe it's taking some time to run
but basically i can see that the
separator is is not complete and the
header is not okay
why is this
let's clear the console let's run it one
more time
okay something strong with this console
for me
okay did any one of you got this working
in this console
okay something wrong with me let's
refresh this control for me
no you did not try
maybe you can try it in collab yeah
for some reasons it's not working it
should work
[Music]
it's still loading up for me okay
let's go go down so in the try it
yourself section
let's upload the files one more time
my internet is really slow today
or my computer is taking a long time to
load
yeah it's not wait it's
being unresponsive yes okay got there
go up go up go up come on
okay let me stop my share and start my
share one more time maybe it will work
yeah until then yeah i couldn't use it
it doesn't respond until then can you
please maybe many of us are
using it for the for the same time
that's why the console is not responding
if you have any other queries please let
me know until i get this
working
next we are going to deal with how to
uh
subset or index the uh
um
yeah
how to index uh
the data frame that we have ready so
that we will definitely do
let's see
okay uh we will deal with that one and
then we'll we may be maybe we can come
back to this lesson
it's still not responding to me
okay now i can share my screen again
maybe just this time you can respond
okay can you see my screen
okay let's try import numpy again one
more time run this
this console worked
so
yeah
i think many of us are accessing this
for the for
for the same time that's why it's
actually freezing
it's not working
yes uh question please go ahead and
manuel
okay let's uh bought this and
if you try it i'll try it away from here
it'll work but basically this is what
you should do you should actually
download the file
okay wait it
if i execute this code up in my
workspace i get an error what is the
error that you are getting can you paste
the error that you are getting
can check so we will go to your collab
okay we will go to the collab it's not
okay it actually ran finished here
so it actually ran successfully then
let's try it one more time in this
dropbox
and just drop the file thing
because you have not imported pandas as
pd so import pandas as pd and then do
this then then it will work
let's do this and if i run it's going to
throw me an error
yeah first you have to import pandas pd
only then it will work okay this is not
working let's let's go to um if you have
then you you might not have imported you
might not have run it right here in the
collab
um
are you using collab
you have to execute this
yeah you have to execute this
right you have to execute this only then
it will work like this
uh execute this only then that will work
and then you work
so okay let's obvious code
then it should work uh it should
basically work
okay
so did it work there
so i did not give you any error while
you executed this
if it gave you and it gave you some
error then it might not have worked then
if you have executed this it gives you
does not give you any error
this rather work
yeah because
no but that is numpy right tempo work
you are generating from text file that's
fine but this should work create
underscore table from pd should work uh
d if you copied and paste it try typing
it again one more time maybe there is
some mistake medicine maybe there is
some font issue try typing it instead of
copying and pasting okay let's
quickly uh
we saw how different types can be
accessed and as i mentioned while
dealing with r
um
head can also work here so here we have
loaded everything into df so df
first few lines can be accessed using
head info head
function
just like r but just the calling is
different in in uh
in
python you have to use head of
data frame here you are using data frame
dot head and
that will work and then just like how i
describe how
we can index different samples in
r and the sample types and different
columns and different
rows in r and python in python as i
mentioned you have to